[Musique]
kensington l'un des quartiers les plus
riches de la capitale londonienne c'est
sur ce chantier que ça mc kinney un
irlandais de 30 ans est venu chercher du
travail ça m'a quittée belfast et sa
crise économique qui frappe le pays
depuis 2008
c'est bien d'avoir du boulot et en plus
c'est bien mieux payés que chez moi
le fringant tigre celtique du début des
années 2000 n'est plus que l'ombre de
lui même en irlande le chômage touche
aujourd'hui 14% de la population
c'est ce qui a poussé sam à rejoindre
londres ici ils gagnent plus du double
de son salaire irlandais
j'étais déjà venu ici pendant six ou
sept ans j'avais 18 ans puis je suis
reparti pendant deux ans et là je viens
juste de revenir il ya environ six mois
il ya tellement de perspectives de
travail en angleterre qu'en irlande ici
ça m'a facilement trouver un job sa
chance il la doit à peter hain
compatriotes expatriés depuis plus de 40
ans qui l'a embauché dès son arrivée est
ce que tu peux m'aider la mesure et ça
derrière le mur
dans ce coin et aux alentours le prix de
l'immobilier est très élevé les travaux
de rénovation sont toujours bien payé
pour sam pas besoin deine il fait jouer
le réseau communautaire et 7 aux london
irish un club de rugby irlandais
londonien que sam a rencontré peter son
boss une dodge cheveux secs au club il y
a toujours un ou deux gars qui cherche
du boulot
alors je les appelle et leur demande
s'ils sont disponibles pour à jour de
capotage
samedi après midi ça m'est venu taper le
cuir avec son équipe de rugby du london
irish un club de la banlieue londonienne
son départ des immigrés irlandais en
1890 de place to be pour les irlandais
de londres
c'est le blason de notre club ça
représente l'irlande et ça c'est
l'angleterre et loison qui vole au
dessus ça représente les irlandais qui
se sont envolés d'irlande et qui un jour
rentreront au pays
aujourd'hui est sam et son équipe
composée exclusivement d'irlande 1re as
contre l'équipe anglaise des tonnes
bridge et pour transformer l'essai ils
ont leur botte secrète
l' irish spirit c'est quelque chose de
difficile à décrire c'est un désir de
gagner c'est quand on refuse
d'abandonner de concéder la défaite
c'est toujours se donner à 100% 42%
un peu avant le match dans le restaurant
du club entre les maillots historique et
les photos jaunies de vétérans se tient
le repas annuel des anciens joueurs
les gens qui sont ici ils sont bien
fondés un important au maillot vert et
qu'on le joue aux contres les autres
clubs tous les autres chansons en
anglais et c'est quand nous jouerons le
match international chaque samedi
à table peter le patron de sam et son
ami marc tous deux ont porté haut les
couleurs du club dans les années 70 pour
eux aujourd'hui plus que jamais les
irlandais doivent jouer collectif frappé
de plein fouet par la crise soixante dix
mille d'entre eux ont quitté le pays
l'année dernière et si beaucoup sont
partis vers l'australie ou le canada
londres demeure la destination
privilégiée
le club c'est un foyer pour les
irlandais ici le rapport est inversé
avec l'économie irlandaise
quand l'économie est malade il a plus de
monde au club et quand tout va bien il y
a moins d'adhérents en irlande on est
toujours que lorsqu'une maladie est
mortelle c'est qu'il n'y a rien de grave
en ce moment les gens vont très mal mais
les irlandais vont s'en sortir
ce sera une lutte acharnée où l'on en
sortira vainqueur
15h le début du match cet après midi sam
et ses potes second au classement a fait
les premiers de leur poule une rencontre
au sommet
aujourd'hui ils s'inclineront 18 à 12
heureusement la saison est encore longue
pour ce petit quinze du trèfle 1
le lendemain un séjour de metz dans le
quartier irlandais de willesden green
comme tous les dimanches l'église
catholique de sainte marie madeleine
accueille ses fidèles
[Musique]
ce matin au programme de christina et de
son fiscal and office religieux pouvoir
prier sans avoir peur paraît aujourd'hui
naturel mais ce n'est qu'au début du
xxème siècle que l'angleterre
protestante a cessé de tyranniser les
catholiques on a été opprimé il était
interdit de pratiquer sa religion
interdit d'être catholique
parce que l'éducation était religieuse
donc en opprimant la religion catholique
on empêchait l'éducation c'est comme ça
qu'on sommet le peuple
merci pour ma famille tous les amis que
tu m'as donné
guînes mois dans l'obscurité de la nuit
et dans le soleil du matin amène même
j'ai appris ça à l'école ma montre
c'est dans les années 30 que des
paroissiens irlandais ont financé de
nombreuses églises comme celle ci c'est
donc l'immigration qui a ouvert la voie
à la religion catholique sur ce sol
protestants
[Musique]
catholicisme était très faible jusqu'il
ya 150 ans en angleterre
l'immigration des irlandais constitue la
plus grande partie des catholiques ici
ça a été la base du renouvellement et
aujourd'hui encore beaucoup de
catholiques sont liées aux irlandais
[Musique]
cris cloud dans le nord-est de londres
c'est ici que s'est installé une partie
des 200 milles irlandais de la capitale
aujourd'hui et christina fêtes le repas
de noël avec les retraités de la
diaspora c'est son association le bias
qui organise l'événement
[Musique]
bien maintenant on est prêt dans les
années 50 des dizaines de milliers
d'irlandais fuyant une importante
récession sont arrivés à londres
aujourd'hui retraité c'est avec humour
qu'il se souvienne des heures les plus
difficiles
il y avait beaucoup de discrimination
contre les irlandais il y avait beaucoup
d'endroits interdit aux irlandais et
honore pas de boulot et pas de logement
le bias l'association de christina est
financée par l'état irlandais mais cette
année marasme économique oblige les
budgets sont à sec l'emploi de christina
et même menacer
le gouvernement irlandais n'a pas encore
décidé combien d'argent ils allaient
envoyer à l'étranger pour des
associations comme la nôtre il n'y aura
peut-être même plus d'argent du tout pas
question pour autant de se laisser
abattre aujourd'hui place au swing
[Musique]
changement de génération mais pas de
tradition on retrouve ça mais c'est
rugbyman pour une soirée arrosée dans
l'un des nombreux pubs irlandais de saut
le quartier branché de la capitale
ici entre bière et musique irlandaise la
crise paraît bien loin
[Musique]
ça c'est un vieux maillot de leinster la
banque d'irlande ne sponsorise plus le
club à cause de la crise
la banque on s'en fout le plus important
c'est leinster
[Musique]
23h l'alcool coule à flots tout le monde
se lâche même dans le petit
confessionnal installée au fond du bar
mon père je bois trop je fume trop et je
crois que je me masturbe trop dans la
masturbation c'est ok mais arrête de
boire tu feras 80 maria va en paix avec
dieu au nom du père du fils et du
saint-esprit amen et à la tienne à la
tienne mec comme dans tous les pubs
irlandais de la planète et sam et ses
acolytes se sentent à la maison crise ou
pas la troisième mi-temps et génétique
chez les irlandais et le peuple n'est
pas prêt de déposer le bilan
gaza
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]